bonjour à tous je m'appelle marielle m
de la chambre de métiers et de
l'artisanat de l'essonne je vous
souhaite la bienvenue et vous remercier
de participer à la quatrième édition de
la journée découverte des métiers de
l'artisanat organisé par la chambre de
métiers et ses partenaires la faculté
des métiers d'essonne le cfa du bâtiment
de brétigny sur orge et les apprentis
d'auteuil du lycée horticole paysager de
simples en toi saint-antoine de
marcoussis les sites web conférence que
nous proposons aujourd'hui dans le cadre
de la semaine nationale de
l'apprentissage sont consacrés à
l'orientation des jeunes vers les
métiers de l'automobile du bout de la
fleuristerie de la beauté et du bâtiment
avant de commencer je voudrais
simplement vous livrer quelques
informations importantes sur le secteur
de l'artisanat et sur l'apprentissage
qui attire de plus en plus de jeunes
ainsi que des personnes en reconversion
cherchant à exercer un métier concret et
créatif
l'artisanat représente en france plus
d'un million trois cent mille
entreprises on l'appelle pour cela la
première entreprise de france c'est
aussi 250 milles entre pylônes
ile-de-france et 31 villes en essonne un
apprenti sur trois est formé dans une
entreprise artisanale ce qu'il faut
surtout savoir c'est que la formation en
apprentissage offre de belles
perspectives d'avenir avec 80 % des
apprentis qui trouvera un emploi dans
les six mois qui suivent leur formation
c'est aussi l'opportunité pour chacun
d'envisager de créer une entreprise
41% des dirigeants d'entreprise
aujourd'hui on était apprenti voilà de
quoi alimenter nos discussions et
surtout nous espérons que cet événement
suscitera des vocations
place maintenant à la présentation du
métier de fleuriste autour de la table
nous accueillons je vous laisse vous
présenter
il a appris ce temps deuxième année
à 10,6 contre fleury sont désabonnés
je suis madame chalabrais je suis la
formatrice au lycée horticole de
marcoussis donc formatrice dans les
matières professionnelles et notamment
en art floral
bonjour je suis monsieur denis donc moi
je suis responsable ingénierie
pédagogique et développement des
formations au lycée campus saint fons
alors n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions
nous et répandre en fin de présentation
pour votre information cette
présentation est enregistrée
alors le
oui donc le métier de fleuriste
vous connaissez certainement des
fleuristes autour de chez vous donc le
métier de père et c'est un métier qui
est plutôt créatif mais qui nécessitent
également d'avoir différentes
compétences notamment sur la gestion
donc c'est un métier que l'on apprend
pour la majorité en majorité du temps en
apprentissage donc l'apprentissage
il peut se faire directement après la
troisième donc quand on a à peu près 15
ans et dans ces cas-là il s'effectue sur
deux ans au cf mais c'est aussi un
métier que l'on peut apprendre plus tard
dans son parcours scolaire ou
professionnelle notamment pour les gens
qui sont reconversion mais pas que après
le baccalauréat par exemple et il va
s'effectuer sur un an donc nous au lycée
horticole nous donc nous prenons des
apprentis et ils doivent donc trouver un
maître d'apprentissage avant d'intégrer
le cursus
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en
effet il faut avoir minimum 15 ans pour
aller en apprentissage ça c'est là le
premier point important
sur le rythme en effet en entreprise
vous avez 35 heures maximum par semaine
vous bénéficiez en effet comme comme un
salarié en fin de compte les ses cuisses
sociale et de l'eau de la législation et
vous avez droit à cinq semaines de
congés payés comme tous les salariés
entre eux de la fin de votre contrat
vous êtes aussi un caniveau métier
reconnu
parce que le king mieux à deux aux jo
j'ai tout dit m
[Musique]
alors là après la bourse c'est que c'est
vrai
donc pas de travail et donc
effectivement en étant attentif et bien
m'en des salariés de l'entreprise
on va maintenant vous passez une vidéo
que vous preniez connaissance
métier de fleuriste
en vidéo
pour je suis dire j'ai déjà la presse je
suis formatrice et professeur principal
du crt fleurissent au lycée saint
antoine
[Musique]
alors comment atteindre retour le chp
puristes le cht fleuriste on peut
l'intégrer après la troisième et dans ce
cas la c1 ce qu'a fait caen va effectuer
en deux ans on court aussi l'intégrer
plus tard dans le parcours scolaire
notamment après le bac ou en
reconversion professionnelle et dans ce
cas là c'est un ca fais tu va
s'effectuer en un an
c'est un ca fait qui s'effectue en
alternance avec 15 semaines par an au
lycée et 32 semaines environ en
entreprise
en ce qui concerne les pour laisser a
fait deux ans nous avons un mélange de
matières professionnelles et de matières
générales dans les matières générales
les élèves suivront des cours de
français de mathématiques histoire géo
et d'anglais pour les matières
professionnelles nous avons par exemple
des matières comme la reconnaissance des
végétaux ou le dessin la botanique les
technologies professionnelles pour
apprendre le métier de fleuriste et d
atelier d'une journée pour apprendre et
florales les élèves souffrant un certain
nombre de suivront qu'il ya matière
professionnelle quelles qualités faut-il
pour devenir fleuriste le métier de
fleuriste est très exigeant il faut donc
être organisées il faut aussi avoir la
fibre artistique et être manuel de ses
mains c'est un métier où il va falloir
être dynamique polyvalent et aussi avoir
un certain sens du commerce donc après
le cercle et secouristes les élèves
peuvent décider de poursuivre leurs
études en fleuristerie et faire un bébé
donc un brevet professionnel en
fleuristerie qui est l'équivalent du bac
à ne rien il y à aussi par la suite un
brevet de maîtrise
certains préfèrent eux directement
rentré dans la vie professionnelle en
doublon fleuriste on peut être floride
en différents lieux par exemple en
boutiques traditionnelles mais aussi
dans des chaînes en libre service dans
les jardineries certains risquent eux
préféreront peut-être ouvre hors micro
entreprise et travailler dans
l'événementiel d'autres vont travailler
plus tôt dans l'hôtellerie ou dans le
domaine touristique comme par exemple
dans des camps par quatre
donc on va maintenant vous présenter le
métier de fleuriste à nouveau
et l'uefa du campus saint-antoine
alors le campus saint-antoine qu est un
établissement de la fondation apprentis
d'auteuil je rappelle apprentis
d'auteuil ses 240 établissements en
france
danser nous sommes implantés en effet
alors la fondation à 155 ans le campus
lycée horticole à 80 ans il se situe
donc dans un dans un domaine de 14
hectares à marcoussis qui est proche de
paris et on propose en effet à des
jeunes tout horizon coude donc leur
avenir ans formant un métier en lien
avec le paysage la nature l'horticulture
la fleuristerie et mes services aux
personnes par la voie scolaire ou la
voie de l'apprentissage
donc charles la partie donc sans de
formation on a deux métiers le métier de
fleuriste ans est happé et du paysage
avec des seat et aider les pays où
pasqua donc une soixantaine d'apprentis
on a également donc un déficit de
prévoir quand tissage sa tête propulse
qui tint en effet d'accueillir des
jeunes en quête nouvelle scolarité ou en
recherche d'apprentissage
or justement les deux sets
d'apprentis aujourd'hui
né vers le métier de fleuriste elle est
votre parcours
mais vous savez de conversion gérer une
scolarité en 3e générale et j'ai
découvert le métier de fleuriste à mon
stage de 3e ça m'a beaucoup plu du coup
je ne sais pas je ne veux pas faire je
veux pas faire un parcours autres et je
me suis lancé dans le servait
fleuriste et ça fait maintenant deux ans
vu que je suis apprentie en serbe et
fleuristes et je compte par la suite
faire le vide et flou
donc pour ma part par heinz scolarité
jusqu'en 3e ou jacques rocher pas du
tout l'école et j'ai découvert en sang
des mini-stages le métier de fleuriste
que j'ai apprécié du coup je partis
ampleur historique
très bien
un petit quizz peut-être
savez vous combien d'apprentis il ya une
chef d'entreprise après leurs études
pour 150 % contre 30 %
bravo 50% certainement assez exactement
la bonne réponse
effectivement la moitié des enfants
filles ou à une entreprise une boutique
de fleurs se mettre à leur compte après
après leur apprentissage
la prochaine
alors
cécile
donc c'est bien cécile notre maîtrise de
l'apprentissage va vous donner quelques
conseils pour bien vivre votre formation
en amoureux message en tant qu'apprenti
oui c'est plutôt des conseils
pratiques pour on va dire bien enclenché
son apprentissage parce que c'est pas
c'est pas forcément facile de partir de
la 3e et dure au lendemain
être salarié d'une entreprise
alors qu'on était élève
donc voilà c'est trois petits conseils à
ses et qui me paraissent importants pour
bien enclenché cette cet apprentissage
effectivement montré sa motivation en
premier lieu c'est important ça englobe
beaucoup beaucoup de choses montrer sa
motivation ça ça peut être par exemple
sur la ponctualité il faut vraiment bien
garder à l'esprit est effectivement je
pense que ça a été dit c'est un contrat
d'apprentissage donc vous êtes vous fait
partie intégrante d'une entreprise
du jeu donc d'une équipe donc l'équipe
ne peut pas
se permettre de vous attendre tout ça
donc effectivement gardez bien en tête
que la ponctualité 7 c'est important
mais ça ça prouve aussi votre motivation
de bonne volonté aussi vous avez droit
de vous tromper c'est quelque chose
d'important ou si vous êtes là pour ça
aussi
vous avez tout à fait le droit de vous
tromper mais effectivement tout change
contre la volonté et
vous voyante voilà de effectivement
de dire qu'il fait quand ça quand j'ai
fini ma fine une tâche de demander une
autre tâche ou est ce que ça va j'ai
bien fait les choses s'emballent
n'hésitez pas surtout à a montré que
vous avez envie de bien de faire en tout
cas même si vous faites des erreurs
c'est pas grave effectivement ça prouve
aussi ça prouve aussi votre motivation
voilà donc c'est vraiment un tout un tas
de savoir être en entreprise et de
savoirs savoir se comporter
voilà donc surtout surtout ça c'est un
conseil précieux pour bien enclenchée
dans l'apprentissage en deuxième point
il ya effectivement se passer de son
téléphone portable
ça c'est un point très très très
compliqué surtout alors déjà pour nous
c'est compliqué on aime tous notre
téléphone portable vous rassure mais
alors vous c'est encore pire puisque
vous êtes né avec et que c'est votre
troisième main donc et on comprend on
comprend quand il est bien utilisé
ça peut être une très bonne source
d'information et tout ça mais quand vous
êtes à l'école vous n'avez pas votre
portable donc surtout voilà garder
surtout ça en mémoire on n'est pas à
100% dans ce qu'on fait quand on a un
téléphone portable c'est pas quelque
chose forcément qu'il se fait ni à
l'école ni en entrée et encore moins à
l'entreprise voilà et l'employeur en
plus ce n'est pas un formateur donc il
n'est pas formé non plus pour être
derrière mon constamment pour vous pour
vous reprendre à l'heure à l'ordre donc
il peut le bleu peut-être laissé passer
une fois deux fois que savall agacé
parce que voilà ce qu'il ce qui est
normal et du coup on arrive à des
conflits qui sont
facilement évitables
voilà donc si j'ai un conseil à vous
donner effectivement c'est d'essayer à
un maximum de se passer de ce fameux
téléphone portable vous aller le
retrouver il n'y a aucun souci avec ça
vous avez des pauses au même titre qu'à
l'école et vous aurez plein de messages
aux revenants et ce sera ça titre est
satisfaisant pour vous verrez quand vous
allez de retrouver est vraiment voilà
faire faire des efforts là dessus c'est
important et les conflits démarre par
des petites choses comme ça voilà fond
on est un petit peu conscients
et puis le troisième point qui est aussi
très important
c'est de solides solliciter ses échanges
avec son maître d'apprentissage
alors pourquoi parce qu'effectivement
beaucoup de conflits peuvent arriver
juste par manque de communication en
fait ça arrive ça arrive assez souvent
c'est un peu dommage aussi donc moi si
j'ai vraiment un conseil à vous donner
c'était effectivement de prendre juste
cinq minutes
alors ça dépend des cfa il ya des cfa ou
c'est une semaine entreprises une
semaine école
ou deux semaines entreprise de semaine
école moi je vous invite effectivement à
faire un tout petit point de 5 minutes
avec votre maître d'apprentissage à la
fin de votre semaine
d'entreprise pour faire juste le point
sur tout bas surtout au début pour
s'auto évaluer et voir ce qu'il va skins
qui a été ce qui n'a pas été ce qu'il
faut corriger ce qu'il faut au contraire
là où vous avez été bon donc
effectivement ça peut vous valorisez
aussi s'est dit également vous allez
vous allez en faisant ça
avoir une proximité et une complicité
avec votre maître d'apprentissage et c
c'est juste primordiale pour que ça se
passe bien
au sein d'une entreprise de se dire les
choses qu'ils vont et les choses qui
vont pas en tout en toute transparence
sans qu'il y ait de problèmes ensuite on
est on y arrive seulement avec des
échanges francs et directs sans tabou en
fait d'accord donc si je vous dis pas
que c'est simple mais effectivement
c'est trois petits conseils et là
je pense sont sont trois points à
à mettre en oeuvre effectivement pour
pour bien enclenché son son
apprentissage voilà
vous êtes d'accord
[Musique]
à voir avec lui les points qui sont
positifs et puis ceux qui sont à réunir
et
si compliqué expliqué généralement dans
si c'est une grosse boîte le bâton n'a
pas forcément le temps occupé
personnellement
du petit salarié de l'apprenti donc si
généralement peu demandé aux collègues
faut demander aux personnes qui sont la
tension appliquée le patron chez un
point général il aller retour des
collègues justement et si besoin il y
ont fait un retour autrement dit c'est
compliqué de parler au patron mon prénom
les petites boîtes on n'a plus accès à
parler pour parler avec nos patrons mais
c'est compliqué certainement c'est pour
ça que c'est un point c'est un poids ou
qui
le met à penser ça n'a pas forcément le
temps c'est bien pour ça que le fait d'
enclencher ça dès le début en fait c'est
un en fait c'est d'instaurer sa limite
que ce soit un rituel et d'instaurer ça
dès le départ c'est là où tout le monde
conseil comme ça va effectivement au
bout d'un moment vu que ça se fera un
petit peu tout le temps bon alors je
vous dis pas que au bout d'un moment 3 4
- oui ça c'est ça ça se passe ça se
passera forcément mais effectivement si
ça ne se fait pas du côté du maître
d'apprentissage et que vous voyez que
effectivement ça ne vient pas vous
n'hésitez pas à le solliciter pour faire
cette petit ce petit échange même si
c'est sans lunettes et fiction c'est
très important
voilà il faut il faut le solliciter si
ça ne se fait pas naturellement et puis
ça on pourra pas vous le reprocher ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on pourra jamais
vous reprocher
voilà c'est pour ça que voilà dès le
début parce que je sais qu'après une
fois qu'on est dans la routine
effectivement de l'apprentissage parce
qu'il est évident qu'ils ont autre chose
à faire et que c'est très très prenant
si c'est mis en place dès le départ ce
sera beaucoup plus compliqué de
que de se perdre en fait l'action voilà
merci vous
suivent le pas pour le parcours
donc le parcours de formation comment on
l'a évoqué beaucoup de jeunes deviennent
à s'inscrire en pensiez ap après la
classe de troisième
avec ou sans obtention du brevet des
collèges on a aussi des jeunes qui par
exemple après un ca paix horticole
décide de faire ainsi ap complémentaires
en floride
du coup c'est un ca paix qui s'effectue
en alternance donc les jeunes à
vendargues de rentrer
en formation recherche un maître
d'apprentissage et en termes de rythme
scolaire ils vont être à peu près 15
semaines par an au centre de formation
et
trente deux semaines par an en
entreprise donc en gros deux semaines en
entreprise une semaine à l'école parfois
un peu plus espacés qu'on a des fêtes en
ces moments là les jeunes restent en
entreprise pour gagner en expérience en
terme de cours on a deux types de
courants là les cours qui sont de
l'enseignement général avec des matières
qui vont retrouver du collège comme le
français les maths les sciences mais
aussi donc de l'économie de l'histoire
géographie et du sport il ya également
de l'anglais qui est devenu obligatoire
et puis on a des matières
professionnelles
notamment donc du coup une journée par
semaine de travaux pratiques de
d'atelier mais aussi tout ce qui est
apprentissage de reconnaissance des
végétaux de la biologie du dessin et les
cours de vente voilà donc au lycée nous
c'est long quand les pousse un petit peu
se dépasser et notamment à travers des
concours auxquels ils peuvent s'inscrire
et j'ai en tête notamment le concours de
meilleur apprenti de france contre on
essaye de développer pour que les jeunes
vraiment et s'inscrivent chaque année
c'est une expérience qui est assez riche
et qui est assez forte donc on les
pousse en ce sens et du coup l'examen
c'est un examen final qui est délivrée
par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale et qui se déroule entre le
mois d'avril et le mois de juin
de notre
formation en apprentissage
traditionnel on va dire sens est reparti
en entreprise
rester concentré sur les courts c'est un
peu compliqué donc forcément alterner
les semaines de cours et dans
l'entreprise c'est moins lâchant que
d'être tout le temps devant cfa où on a
que deco ou rayés de la pratique
contrairement à une entreprise
ou côté variés du cou à changer de
rythme changer d'interlocuteur c'est ça
qui vous a le plus plu en apprentissage
et de votre côté bah c'est pas c'est les
courses un peu ennuyant juste rester
assis écouter
bouger faire de soi même c'est largement
plus gratifiant que juste rester assis
écoutez quoi
c'est mieux cotées ont beau jeu c'est
assez physique en plus c'est vrai
donc et dans le métier lui-même
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui vous plaît
en fait qu'est-ce qui vous plaît le plus
dans ce métier à quoi est-ce que vous
commencez à bien connaître mono
basse et permettent de pouvoir créer
avec
les différents végétaux comme ans au cfa
et en entreprise
et c'est vrai que la créativité c'est
c'est mieux que de rester en cours comme
tout l'excellent normal de vent proches
surtout que vous avez un métier très
créatif
[Musique]
c'est ça le le mieux c'est de rendre un
client c'est qu'on nous apporte des
fleurs etc ont constitué en bouquets
devant lui le voir s'émerveiller si le
bouquet lui a plus et c'est le meilleur
clairement c'est la meilleure chose
action c'est ça
près derrière il ya toutes les tâches
comme l'arrivage des fleurs les coupes
et les mettre en bottes serveur client
il y en a qui sont pas non plus super
sympa
donc il faut faire avec le prendre sur
soi pour rester professionnel c'est un
métier oui il ya aussi il ya non
seulement l'aspect créatif la sptr vous
dire un peu technique il ya l'aspect
relationnel et commercial que vous avez
sur sur le terrain que vous apprenez
effectivement chouette bon botteur vente
mon vendeur où je sors on peut pas en
drames en course et ces complémentaires
en fait
on va voir plutôt la théorie et on va
faire des simulations c'est vrai que
c'est les choses qui y pratiquent plus
grandes entreprises
et donc j'imagine qu'un bouquet sa
singes commencera à faire un bouquet
quand même pour quitter le bien être les
harmonies de couleurs est ce que vous
avez à premier
[Musique]
un peu des deux on apprend sur le tas
nos collègues sont là derrière aussi
pour nous soutenir on n'est pas n'est
pas tout seul
on apprend aussi en cours on a notre
propre nos professeurs que nous apprend
laisse à associer les couleurs par thème
par mas la forme
février que bouquet soir on c'est
l'emballage
c'est toute une technique petit une
technique
surtout procès ap le bouquet faut qu'il
tienne debout tout seul marcil a vrillé
mal fait il va nous perdre et ça tient
pas c'est ça
ok et dans l'examen il ya à la fois de
la théorie de la pratique quand ça
fonctionne n'est qu'un madit-crt ces
salles d'examen du cmp pour la pratique
il me semble qu'ils intègrent le descend
de dons si je me trompe pas donc on doit
faire un croquis préalable à ce qu'on
doit réaliser pour l'épreuve du s'est
rappelé et
oui donc oui parce que généralement on
tombe sur le thème mariage si je ne
trouve pas ça dépend des années mais
faut tous remontés tiges à tige par
fleur donc vous il ya la théorie de
dents qui qui joue aussi sur les points
ouais pour l'examen c'est un mélange
entre des leaf est qu'ils ont écrit et
qui sont finalement de la théorie de
l'apprentissage de la théorie il ya
également la pratique donc une mise en
situation mais il ya aussi pas mal de
mes examens qui se passe à l'oral
notamment l'examen de vente et pendant
les deux années donc en ces api leur
constituent également des dossiers dans
différentes matières notamment
d'histoire géo en anglais en vente etc
des présentations qu'ils se font à
l'oral donc ça c'est vraiment les pousse
à devenir
compétents et assez autonomes pour
arriver à présenter un travail qu'ils
ont effectué à l'oral et être à des
joueurs
importants après dans la partie
commerciale en fait c'est ça
on peut peut-être voir si vous voulez
aller plus loin comment va comment
s'inscrire
à prendre
alors pour s'inscrire c'est extrêmement
ça nous avons une quantité
impressionnante de journées portes
ouvertes dont l'une aura lieu dans deux
jours le 5 février de 9h30 à 12h30
directement au campus saint-antoine à
marcoussis vous avez après d'autres
dates 1 le 12 mars après le mercredi
aussi le 16 mars le 26 mars au 9 avril
18 mai d'intérêt mais 11 juin qu'un ce
jour vous retrouverez ces dates là au
niveau de notre site internet qui
recense toutes ces informations et sur
lequel vous pourrez en effet vous
inscrire pour venir aligne ses portes
ouvertes
la deuxième possibilité qui est très
importante qui peut être et où
suite à une porte ouverte c'est de faire
un mini stage sur notre plateau
technique et puis aussi de faire des
tests
pour en effet facile métier tu adaptes
effectivement se rendre à une journée
portes ouvertes je pense que c'est
important ça permet de dialoguer sur
site de voir ce qu'on appelle des
plateaux techniques effectivement le
lieu d'accueil des matériels à votre
disposition
de voir d'autres apprentis vous avez
déjà des apprentis qui sont venus qui
sont venus voir mais bien sûr qu'il ya
d'autres pourront vous recevoir sur site
avec leurs professeurs et les
responsables
roumains vous donne aussi le nom des
personnes à contacter les informations
mais en attente pour nous contacter
le plus simple évidemment sur internet
ou sur google vous tapez campus
saint-antoine marcoussis là vous
trouverez directement mais sinon vous
avez donc l'adresse du site web qui
s'affiche donc c'est un tir et antoine
point apprentis ou plurielle tirer
auteuil point org
vous a aussi la possible vous appelez
directement adapté dont human rêver
redit que la personne qui prend en
charge les inscriptions pour les
journées portes ouvertes et pour tout
autre renseignement
sinon on les envoyait un mail qui
affiche six lits pour interdite at
apprentis tirer auteuil points
enfin dernier lieu nous sommes situés
donc à 15 minutes en bus de la gare rer
b donc or c'est au mas i ou les versets
vocal samedi s'appellent chorges sachez
que devant notre site de leurs consignes
à un arrêt de bus en fait qui parle de
relance en que ces deux gars directement
on disait tout à l'heure effectivement
qu'un apprentissage c'était une école et
une entreprise ça implique effectivement
de rechercher de rechercher une
entreprise donc rechercher une
entreprise
souvent c'est un point bas qui est un
petit peu inquiète 1 1 pour oi pour les
jeunes qui souhaitent qui souhaitent se
lancer donc déjà est ce que
l'école aide à trouver à une entreprise
qui voulaient jacques commandement
du côté de l'école on a effectivement à
créer une base de données d'entreprise
surtout sur la région l'essonne proche
de ma peau si
nous mettons à jour au fur et à mesure
20 du nombre d'apprentis qu'ils ont pu
recevoir et comment ça s'est passé du
coup quand les jeunes ils recherchent un
maître d'apprentissage dans cette zone
là nous leur donnons une liste de
sociétés a contacté mais ils ont aussi
la possibilité d'élargir leurs
recherches à d'autres villes d'autres
départements voire à d'autres régions
vous êtes arrivé d'avoir des élèves qui
n'étaient même pas en région ile de
france donc ça c'est pas un souci et
bien sûr quoi qu'il en soit les des
professeurs formateurs ou des éducateurs
du lycée sont là aussi pour accompagner
les jeunes dans leur recherche de maître
d'apprentissage
avoir un maître d'apprentissage pour
commencer la formation n'est pas
obligatoire mais par contre ils ont un
délai je crois de deux mois maintenant
dominique pour rechercher le maître
d'apprentissage et durant ces deux mois
quand ils n'ont pas de maître
d'apprentissage nous sommes là pour les
accompagner donc on peut à la fois
appelé les sociétés les aider à faire
leur cv leur lettre de motivation les
coacher pour être prêt pour pour
rencontrer un même apprentissage il faut
bien se dire que c'est maintenant
trouver l'entreprise au moment où vous
entrez en apprentissage au cfa
vous aurez un accompagnement pour pour
vous aider justement à trouver
l'entreprise savoir comment présenter
votre cv une lettre de motivation
comment vous présentez vous aussi
directement quand vous allez rencontrer
un employeur potentiel ça fait partie de
l'accompagnement retrouver en cfa alors
on va justement voir vous comment vous
avez été au départ dont ça s'est passé
pour trouver votre employeur en tant que
jeune apprenti moi j'ai eu de la chance
parce que le nom patron actuel mon
maître d'apprentissage actuelle ça a été
également
mon maître de stage qui m'a appelé ce
stage de 3e c'est ça qui m'a par la
suite pris en maître d'apprentissage
voilà
pour moi je suis allé voir certaines
boutiques je suis allé faire toutes les
boutiques autour de chez moi je suis
manches par 6 demander directement en
face ils prenaient des apprentis si
c'était possible j'ai eu quelques
réponses
j'ai des rendez vous il y en a qui
étaient pas d'accord nike était ok donc
je tombais je suis une bonne entreprise
et voilà je crée je suis allé
directement pour présenter ça veut dire
que du coup tu avais même plusieurs
opportunités a été choisie lunel
je suis tombé sur premièrement sur une
boutique qui était pas top donc suite à
ça j'ai changé j'ai eu deux propositions
je vais choisir une et ça se passe bien
bon bah c'est encourageant mais
encourageant alors je rebondis sur
un départ de professionnels forcément on
le sait bien c'est pas un stage qui
permet d'observer c'est comme ça
meilleur stage d'observation ce qui peut
se passer dans une entreprise et on sait
bien que très souvent on va dans
l'entreprise de d'un parent ou d'un ami
connu mais c'est vrai que si vous avez
déjà une petite idée du métier que vous
auriez voulu
faire au moins connaître un peu mieux
c'est une bonne manière de bien
d'appréhender en fait un devoir ce qui
se passe et pourquoi pas c'est
effectivement ça s'est passé dans votre
cas va poursuivre en apprentissage si ça
si ça se passe bien dans tous les cas un
employeur préférera choisir s'il a
plusieurs demandes un jeune qu'il
connaît déjà et qu'il a
apprécié même si cette période courte
comme une simple semaine alors sachez
aussi qu'il est toujours possible de
faire des stages
en dehors de ce stage obligatoire de 3
yens vous avez la possibilité de faire
des stages pendant les vacances
scolaires
il suffit de vous adresser à la chambre
la chambre de métiers relations de
commerce et nous avons des conventions
qui permettent d' entre 1 et 5 jours par
vacances d'essayer comme ça ou de
d'entrée en observation dans une
entreprise
pour pour découvrir un pour découvrir le
métier donc c'est un complément avec
effectivement le pistage qu'on peut
faire sur certains au centre de
formation campus
de saint-antoine à artistique justement
alors est ce que est ce que vous auriez
des questions
auxquelles vous souhaiteriez que que
nous répondions
l'établissement mais en troisième est-ce
alors suite à une réunion avec le prince
le professeur principal de mon fils il
m'a parlé d' intégrer votre
établissement mais en troisième est ce
possible
c'est possible d'intégrer le lycée
effectivement sur la classe de troisième
mais ça sera pas dans une troisième
fleuristerie parce que lâche le riz
story c'est après la troisième c'est un
siècle est donc là ça sera une classe de
3e
horticole non
récemment donc une troisième porte
parole donc ça c'est possible
effectivement je crois que même dès la
4e c'est possible dans notre
établissement
dès la 4e
alors
c'est vraiment
les classes de 4e 3e en qu'il colle qui
sont existantes et du coup il ya des
jeunes qui viennent pour passer la 4e à
3e avec une malle avec une
spécialisation dans l'horticulture et
après ça je vais intégrer le cercle
horticole de ces affiches fleurissent
temps s'appelait paysage sans souci
c'est
j'ai fait une perte du 4ème comment on
peut avoir dans un rang collet général
avec une spécialisation
oui de la nature et de ses quatrièmes et
troisièmes seront de l'enseignement
agricole voila voila parlant ça veut
dire effectivement à la jeunes de 5e qui
peut s'orienter
vers les métiers de l'horticulture
directement
et pour intégrer il ya été marche
pacifique à faire à partir de mai je
pense que tous les jeunes qui ont envie
de voir qu'est ce que c'est qu'un lycée
agricole pas venir au lycée au moment
des portes ouvertes de la même manière
que pour la fleuristerie poser les
questions venir peut-être également
découvrir comment ça se passe au 10 et
peut être même avec des périodes de
stars pour les 4e 3e du dauphin et du
coup nous ces élèves là qui sont des
gens 4e 3e s'ils ont envie de tester la
flore il le faut un gagnant dans tous
les angles j'ai des petits troisième qui
devait mener c'est
exactement c'est la meilleure solution
c'est ça c'est la porte ouverte à quoi
le premier dans deux jours la suivante
en tout cas ce qui permet en effet de
venir voir le site de pouvoir échanger
avec des enseignants qui sont présents
de pouvoir dialoguer et après en effet
le stage qui est une deuxième question
et ça ce sera à partir du mois de mars
moi je conseille vivement d'ailleurs les
jeunes qui viennent au fort du père de
venir ont également testé les ateliers
ils peuvent venir passer l'âge où on est
a pratiqué les fleurs avec les élèves et
c'est vraiment là où quelque chose va se
déclencher je pense est-ce qu'ils vont
aimer ou ne pas aimer mais en tout cas
c'est là où ils vont faire leur choix ça
veut dire que c'est un jour pris en
semaine là du coup oui donc nous les
images tu préfères va accueillir les
jeunes donc le mardi c'est la journée où
un à des travaux pratiques le lundi en
fait plutôt les matières théoriques donc
fort à la fin il ya beaucoup moins
d'intérêt devenir de lundi donc y
parvenir le mardi toute la journée ou
demi journée après je suppose que c'est
un arrangement avec le professeur
principal de leur collège pour pouvoir
prendre cette demi-journée cette journée
au
lisseur oui c'est ça c'est la question
que je voulais vous poser est comment ça
s'articule avec la présence obligatoire
quand même au collège car en fait il ya
un lien vous avez une relation vous ai
déjà lui-même pas la même en général
c'est plutôt le jeune homme qui fait la
démarche avec son professeur principal
tout à fait ça fonctionne bien d'une
convention de stage la prévention des
risques d'inondation de la bande jean
des points d'accord
on est enfin on a aussi accueilli des
fois ci les professeurs qui font les
démarches et pas les parents qu'on peut
accueillir par exemple trois élèves
d'une même classe qui voudraient faire
ce jour là on teste ça c'est aussi le
signe un trader ok
alors dans les questions que vous vous
posez à quel endroit foot il s'inscrire
pour faire un stage pendant les vacances
scolaires alors
il faut
choisir l'entreprise dans laquelle vous
voulez faire le stage ensuite vous
adresser à la chambre de métiers et de
l'artisanat de l'essonne et on donnera
en fait un une convention un modèle de
convention faire une convention cadre à
remplir qui sera signé à la fois par le
jeune apprenti si les mineurs ses
parents en général mais l'ignorance que
dans ces cas là et le l'entreprise bien
sûr qu'ils qui accueille et la chambre
de métiers donc nous nous avons
également notre notre signature apposée
donc sur 7 sur ce stage est en fait
c'est très peu j'ai envie de vous dire
c'est très simple un c'est vraiment à
les éléments de base et il faut que
chacun ait une assurance mais rassurez
vous l'assurance scolaire que chacun en
général souscrit en début d'année
convient parfaitement pour le sage et
les employeurs ou si leur assurance donc
il faut il faut quand même malgré tout
voilà pouvoir présenter une assurance
pour pour l'année pour le jeune alors
vous avez aussi j'ai vu dans les
questions demandées les dates des
journées portes ouvertes donc on vous a
dit qu'il y avait une samedi déjà samedi
prochain
après il y en ad'autres est-ce qu'on
peut comptabiliser les afficher voilà
donc après vous en avez une le 17 mars
j'ai vu le 12 mars barzola 12 mars le 16
mars
sur le site sous le site
et vous retrouverez aussi sur le site de
la chambre de métiers de l'artisanat les
dates des journées portes ouvertes des
des centres de formation d'apprentis qui
sont là aujourd'hui avec nous donc ça
fait plusieurs plusieurs moyens pour
trouver mais dans la lancée moi je vous
invite à iliad et dès samedi ils voient
qu'on est prêt pourquoi remettre au
lendemain ou presque ce qu'on peut faire
ce qu'on peut faire tout de suite
n'hésitez pas à poser d'autres d'autres
questions sur tout être un petit point
supplémentaire
au lycée il ya aussi des dates qui sont
proposés donc les mardis et quittant
pendant des vacances scolaires pour ceux
qui ne peuvent pas s'absenter du collège
nous les jeunes femmes y sont plus des
élèves et des apprentis ils viennent
aussi parfois prendre des cours pendant
les vacances scolaires donc à voir ce
qui va le découvrir à ce moment là c'est
aussi possible au sein du lycée
alors dans l'intérêt de l'apprentissage
enfin en tout cas l'intérêt de choisir
un apprentissage on en a on an'a pas on
n'a pas développé la partie autonomie
financière mais je pense quand même que
c'est un des éléments qui est important
pour les jeunes de commencer à avoir une
autonomie financière comme comment ça se
passe pour vous cette partie là nous
vous êtes salarié donc vous avez une
rémunération trois
[Musique]
mois
la partie cycle est réveillé par le
patron que vacheron le paye quand on est
en à l'école sauf que si on veut être
interne au lycée c'est les frais
d'internât sont pour nous ce ne sont pas
aux patrons c'est le patron qui paye les
cours mais c'est pas le passe quand ils
payent l'internât
il ya certains jeux
d'ailleurs qui avait que leur salaire
d'apprenti belle un terme à des mois
pour pouvoir avoir leur autonomie
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un internat
un
internat l'on pouvait être défaite
interne vous pouvez aussi des
fonctionnaires quelqu'un doit classique
un internat d'une quarantaine de cela ce
qui nous permet
également il reste là du lundi au
vendredi et puis de vendre travail
reparte à la maison voilà ma canne à
ternat fille et un apparent garçons
n'ont pas pu y aller
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner un
ordre de grandeur de rémunération donc
déjà certains ont peut-être
dépend de son âge et de son nouveau en
première année deuxième année donc pour
un apprenti qui a moins de 18 ans en
première année c'est environ 430 3 euros
pour la première année donc avec une
augmentation pour la deuxième année la
deuxième année il va être payé 625 euros
à cela s'ajoute différentes choses
notamment les heures supplémentaires qui
sont forcément à rémunérer le patron et
après il peut y avoir des primes si
exceptionnel en fonction voilà de la
boutique
si le candidat a plus de 18 entre 18 et
20 ça va être 689 euros la première
année et 818 euros la deuxième année
puis après donc pour les plus de 21 ans
ils sont quasiment smig si on le
laissait afférents en un an sinon c'est
850 euros la première année et 978 euros
la deuxième a dit voilà donc c'est il
faut aussi peut-être dire à ceux qui qui
on aurait besoin c'est un certain qu'on
peut faire bon quand un an qu on est
adulte on va dire qu'on a déjà un
baccalauréat ac a fait qu'on peut faire
en deux ans quand on sort troisième mais
pour ceux qui pourraient avoir certaines
difficultés
scolaires ou autres ou possible une
phrase
ça c'est ça peut être décidé dès le
début vous pas forcément au cours de la
première année mais on peut le faire en
trois ans ce qu'on peut dire aussi c'est
que si jamais vous avez déjà un c ap
passerait aussi ont un homme peut pas
bâtir général est autrement dit un jeune
qui a un diplôme quelque part quelle que
soit diplôme il fera son ca fait en une
année
normalement si le pack halo et c'est le
jeune albert
et il ne passera pas les matières
générales s'il a déjà ainsi ap il va te
faire sur deux ans mais sans passer les
matières générales
d'accord il a quand même deux ans
d'apprentissage
auquel on ne peut pas faire en émane est
chiant
avec juste que ca pire
les à calories un oui c'est un an sans
souci mais dans six mois c'est faisable
en six mois oui en fait ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que la durée finalement de
l'apprentissage qui est au minimum de 6
mois et les matines même ses trois
alliés donc si je comprend bien
et modulable en fonction d'eux en
fonction de chacun en fait on se sent
que ce qui la pelouse qu'il a fait avant
des besoins de chacun donc c'est aussi
une souplesse qui est intéressante
effectivement à prendre en compte dans
le choix de ce métier en fête et de
l'apprentissage se fait l'apprentissage
et je pense que c'est comme ça quelle
que soit l'activité puisque j'avais dit
aussi avoir plus de difficultés que
d'autres ouais je pense que c'est même
très intéressant mais trop beaucoup
et il ya une question aussi la voyez les
mineurs sont qu'il rémunérait bas je
pense qu'on a répondu donc à cette
question parce que effectivement
les mineurs moins de 18 ans ont une
rémunération prévue qui est pas plus
faible que les majeures quand ça veut
dire que par ton devient majeur on
augmente automatiquement oui sa
rémunération d'un autre côté les parents
n'ont pas s'ennuyer années et quand
passent un deuxième maintenant donc il
ya à la fois l'âge et
quelque part son expérience
en deuxième année on a l'expérience de
la première
et puis ce qui peut rassurer les parents
également c'est qu'il ya une grille de
salaires donc légal est de votre côté
oui c'est très encadré et la fête est
finie mollahs ils abattent n'y a pas
trop de surprises en a pas de surprise
il ya un cadre légal et s'est appliqué
par an
et
est ce que
de part justement vous des maîtres
d'apprentissage que vous côtoyez comment
ça se passe a presque y en a pas mal qui
reste après après leur apprentissage
dans l'entreprise
alors après l'apprentissage uc a fait il
ya beaucoup de jeunes mamans rester dans
leur entreprise pour préparer le diplôme
supérieur des brevets professionnels
donc ça arrive souvent qu'un jeune ait
fait ces deux ans et a fait chez le même
employeur que ces deux années de broc
des professionnels dans les jeunes que
j'ai côtoyés au lycée il y en a
également qui ont été employés par la
suite cherchez pas trop quand ça se
passe bien voilà et c'est pas assez pas
toujours le cas mais ça peut arriver
effectivement
très bien
alors
on arrive à la fin août et fin de notre
présentation il vous reste quelques
minutes si vous avez encore des
questions n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas à
le faire via deviennent chat est ce que
pour le petit mot de la fin tous les
deux qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire à
des collégiens qui sera encore un petit
peu hésitant et corée qui se disent
tiens j'aimerais bien
j'aimerais bien
j'aimerais bien tenter
[Musique]
je vis bien sûr vous êtes motivés
ouais c'est le plus important pour
s'accrocher pour dire que c'est un
métier facile c'est comme nous faut
travailler faut il faut pas avoir peur
d'essayer des choses c'est un métier
créatif avant tout donc faut pas avoir
peur d'essayer tout ce qui vous passe
par la tête et demande à votre patron si
si besoin vos collègues faut vraiment
s'accrocher et voilà faut passer des
moments peut-être un peu difficile on
s'accroche on peut y arriver en
travaillant regard des roses et des
périodes difficiles comme doute un peu
plus calme bien sûr donc pour
s'approcher ok c'est ça c'est plus
compliqué en période de fêtes en
généralement la première fête des mères
on la sent
pas ce que l'on peut on est un peu
stressé aussi parce que c'est une
première grosse fête confère en tant
qu'apprenti mais il faut pas se
décourager même en première année qu'on
soit en troisième faut quand même faire
un stage de 3e pour voir si on aime ou
pas et par la suite pourquoi pas vers un
partage ce parcours il est bénéfique
c'est ça ça lâche le siège est à bâle
eustache il permet de savoir de savoir
si on aime ou pas déjà est de savoir si
on peut partir sur cette voie là ou pas
ok bah merci beaucoup en super merci à
toute l'équipe
du campus saint-antoine qui vous a
présenté le
métier là la formation pour devenir
fleuriste j'espère que ça vous aura
apporté et bien toutes les informations
dont vous aviez besoin à l'instant et
puis n'hésitez pas à aller sur notre
site internet vous retrouverez
l'intégralité de cette visioconférence
ainsi que l'ensemble des
visioconférences de la journée est il
bien vous avez tous les contacts les
dates des journées portes ouvertes que
vous retrouverez sur les sites internet
de nos très bien sur le site internet du
lycée horticole de campus du campus
saint-antoine de marcoussis à très
bientôt j'espère au revoir